we're following several big developments
there after the mass shooting nor
O'Donnell's near the scene of the
shooting Norah Gayle thank you so much
president Trump and the first lady will
leave the White House shortly to travel
here to Las Vegas they will meet with
victims and their families along with
first responders and state and local
leaders major Garrett is here in Vegas
ahead of the president's arrival major
good morning good morning to you Nora
when President Trump touches down here
this morning he will console those most
deeply affected by America's deadliest
mass shooting survivors and first
responders sadly such events are by no
means new to the American presidency but
mr. Trump's unapologetic support for the
National Rifle Association during the
campaign and now his presidency could
bring new scrutiny the president called
the shooter Steven paddock sick and
demented and the White House has said
now is simply not the time to talk about
gun control or the efforts the president
has already taken to erase gun control
moves put in place by President Obama
it's worth noting in the 1990s and early
2000s mr. Trump supported the assault
weapons ban and in 2012 praised mr.
Obama's response to the Sandy Hook
massacre back to present time there is
little evidence any of the long proposed
gun control measures would have
prevented the mass shooting here the
question for mr. Trump and lawmakers on
Capitol Hill is whether preventing all
mass shootings is the only acceptable
standard or if using new federal laws to
reduce their frequency and lethality
might be all right major
thank you so much